2017 was the year the anime industry
went into overdrive I mean I hope I'm
not the only one who feels this you have
the big boys just [ __ ] pouring in
money trying to get a piece of that pie
more anime coming out than any of us
could ever conceivably watch and the
medium itself starting to break out in
the mainstream consensus in terms of the
actual anime that came out however I'd
say overall it was ok we have the usual
standouts in action slice of life and
romance
II say Kai shows no sign of slowing down
to the point where a piece of my soul
gets transported to another world every
time have to say transported to another
world but we're getting to see the
revival of traditional fantasy again who
would have thought mecha fans though
unfortunately once again were left in
the dust
I'm sorry mecha fans 2018 is gonna be
your year I swear to God but I think was
really missing this year was that new
big breakout hits have really captured
the community alright enough [ __ ]
crunchyroll are once again hosting the
anime Awards and well I know our
memories are still fresh about could
happen last year but they've had time to
listen to the small amount of criticism
that they got and have an entirely new
award system it's not perfect but just
looking at the nominations it's already
a hell of a lot better your vote still
matter but judges hold equal power over
the outcome to avoid this being the URI
or a nice season 2 Awards they've asked
me to give my opinions of the best
things to come out of anime in 2017 for
for disclosure I am NOT being paid to
make this video but they are fly me out
to the events cuz it's gonna be a live
show this year which should be very
interesting and without further ado here
we go
it's no secret a CG and anime have not
had the best relationship for years just
like the two have been put into an
arranged marriage that neither side
wants to be for every small step forward
polygons pictures took with their word
we got a bizarre 2017 taking us so many
steps back we moon walks back to the
Jurassic era and the best we could ever
hope for was something like all 10
episodes yes count them 10 episodes of
Kato the rice answer that could give us
a story interesting enough that we could
look past the CG for me though the worst
thing is a show like any Isshiki weather
CGT is not bad but it's the cost of
switching from 2d to 3d to 2d to 3d to
2d again
oh no wait with 3d again to God just
make up your [ __ ] mind already being
incredibly jarring in any scene that
just makes you want to scream Jesus
Christ just get a divorce already it is
painful to see you to try to force this
and make it work but this year the land
of the lustrous came along and told us
[Music]
[Music]
you know what maybe all those years of
marriage counseling finally did you some
good
[Music]
action is judged by the quality of their
action scenes which in anime of course
is dominated by the good old anime fight
theme which you know a bit of man of and
2017 was no exception
Berta came at carrying Naruto's torch of
putting all your years resources into
one amazing fight play topographer had
some fantastic looking fights but god
damn do I not give a [ __ ] about this
series or any of the characters involved
to let these fights have an impact and
even Kyoto Animation were flexing for
the hell of it with these one or two
little moments they were just like hey
there's a cool fight scene I mean we're
just here making a cute little mojo so
there's nothing we can do to really
compete so don't don't know what came
over me there but a nice my spiciness
the cute in terms of singular big fights
by factoring in overall build up writing
execution and animation my hero academia
just took the piss competing against
itself for the top spot with Deku versus
Todoroki and Spain versus the UA
Alliance then somewhere over here
is Aaron versus the Yama Titan for its
fantastic technical choreography of a
grappler vs Stryker fight I'll also put
kiss shop vs. rrg somewhere in the
middle for its technical prowess and
just how [ __ ] fun and ridiculous it
was now for those wondering where Goku
vs. G Ren is I haven't actually been
watching Dragon Ball super nor do I feel
like marathoning a hundred episodes
right now and for a fight of that
magnitude I'm not just gonna watch it
out of context but from the reaction
I've seen it'll be a contender for the
top spot that being said in terms of
overall action the show that most
consistently put the biggest smile on my
face was recreator z-- which isn't even
a nomination by the way now how can I be
arguing this over other contenders which
are probably technically better executed
well you know what as great as
everything else was I've seen you taka
Nakamura cuts I've seen brilliantly
choreographed fights I've seen well
written and well built up stories
concluded with fists do you know what I
haven't seen [ __ ] magical guns versus
fantasy nice Joe Joe characters versus
visual novel villains
herim love interest getting powered up
and combating fighting game characters a
small mech with a Big Mac versus small
mechs with big mags and a small little
girl
what is even happening these scenes were
the rule of pool on steroids it's a
full-on wet dream for anyone who likes
meta Media and is a fan of anime it's
not perfect it's not completely polished
but god damn is it so much [ __ ] fun
ray hero is a bloody madman for writing
this concept and I salute him for it in
recent times anime films have had a
different treatment internationally
before no matter how excited you were
for a film there'd be no way for you to
watch it unless you invested years of
your life learning Japanese and had a
fresh plane ticket to Japan or
alternatively you could have watched
cameras which I'm sure none of you did
because we're not [ __ ] savages
in contrast 2017 was the year we start
seeing anime films regularly largely
thanks to licensing companies being on
the ball with international releases
quicker than we've ever seen before if a
film was announced there was actually a
chance you'd see some screenings if you
live near a populated area which was
amazing
even though America was there your name
release is more like but thanks to that
your name is up for nomination for Best
Film this year so of course there was
only ever gonna be one pick for my
favorite anime film to get an American
release sword art online ordinal scale
[Laughter]
music and anime is important to me if
you didn't already know but the one mini
shows I watched this year that actively
made me want to go back and listen to
the tracks over and over again recreate
has continued Hiroyuki Serrano's legacy
of composing the same five awesome songs
in his latest attempt to induce pure
unadulterated sound Gazans by blowing
off your eardrums and I still [ __ ]
love it I mean I went to did this show
completely blinded when I first heard
the tracks my first thought was jokingly
tinker jobs were about to hear Soho no
drop hahahahaha where are you [ __ ]
kidding but to me there were only two
clear contenders for the top spot and
they were both fantasy shows Magus price
consistently had pieces that would leave
you in awe of the natural beauty of the
world it was in they'd fit right in with
something like the documentary Planet
Earth that makes you just want to sit
back and reflect on nature's beauty
while setting the tone of this magical
fantastical place and I think with all
the tracks considered it has the
strongest OST overall but in terms of
individual tracks that blew me away I
have to go of Kevin penguins work on
made in abyss I mean I've already used
this drop so many [ __ ] times already
but [ __ ] you this is my video and I want
to hear it again
I could be mowing the lawn washing the
dishes or doing anything else but if I
hear these tracks time stops and it just
immediately transports me to another
world oh no way but but but huge credit
to Kevin banking for composing it or
who's surprisingly enough by his name is
not Japanese who could have known
yes he's actually an Australian bloke
though there's absolutely no way be able
to tell that's just by talking to him
yeah I mean I checked with the main that
he seemed to say that was okay when I
first watched made in the best I wasn't
looking forward to where I took one look
at the poster and thoughts man I don't
want to watch another stupid-ass lolly
adventure slice of life nothing show but
as soon as that first big song hit I was
absolutely blown away I marveled at the
beauty and scale of the journey I was
about to undertake that enveloped me
into this new world I was ready to
explore I was ready to feel and just
with one track it had sold me and the
entire series
last year rocky go was the underground
breakout hit that all the critics were
praising as the one amazing overlooked
drama masterpiece with March comes in
like a lion and foon a well-armed who
left in the back like this year rock ago
came back in full force as the author
pick of the anime that really gave us
the Masterclass
of a beautifully written delicately
crafted drama series and once again
March comes in like a lion seasons he
was there in the back like and as much
as I'm joking about this I'm one of the
people who never got back to a despite
thinking you had an amazing first
episode and hearing from a few people
who did watch it that it was indeed
amazing so with that in mind I don't
think I'm fully equipped to judge this
category as I feel like it's a contest
between these two shows since as great
as the drama in made an abyss and Magus
pride was their strength lies in other
places too and the award really needed
its own fantasy genre award so that
these two shows can Duke it out over the
corpse of every Issei Kai show that have
come out in the past few years I don't
usually like anime comedies it's hard
for me to find a show that doesn't rely
too heavily on anime slapstick or that
one joke being beaten over our heads
continually and any that I do like
usually are only able to get a smaller
chuckle out of me as most so I normally
look over comedy anime compared to other
genres but despite that I found the show
this year that continually had me
rolling around laughing every episode
had something new it did not overstay
its welcome and it was an experience I
could not stop laughing out for one
reason or another and that show was got
a super seasoned neo yo Kyo I am not
joking when talking about animation it's
very easy to focus entirely on action
and fight scenes which we've already
covered so I wanted to take this time to
talk about some miscellaneous things I
just stood out to me visually like land
of the lustrous amazingly dynamic fight
scenes which were not actually my
favorite shots in this show as that
belongs to this long shot of diamonds
this girl trying to hide from a monster
I love the way the camera follows her
around to build that tension and really
get you into her shoes giving that sense
claustrophobia and a shot like this is
something that fully takes advantage of
doing a 3d animator in cinematography
okay not so much animation but speaking
of not animation that Ghibli inspired
landscapes and made an abyss will just
Wow absolutely breathtaking I could
stare a panning shots of these
landscapes all [ __ ] day long because
these were the sexiest things that come
out 2017 show me like you draw one of
your made in abyss backgrounds oh yeah
for real though my favorite animation
this year came out of a silent voice
specifically for the character animation
yes I know it's unfair to compare movie
animation to TV series but tell that to
the judges to express a motion without
any words it's a hard enough skill for
professional actors to convey in
live-action so it blows my mind how
Kyoto Animation were able to do it so
well
with a [ __ ] drawing which is
something we don't see so often in a
medium that has no problem expressing
itself through dialogue and exposition
can you repeat that please I'm not quite
going yet in contrast this girl says
more saying nothing than 90% of anime
characters who can talk all [ __ ] day
long through the nuance of her facial
expression and body language never
before have I seen so many complex
emotions so subtly conveyed in a look or
an action and all I can say is I feel no
one could have tak with this better than
Kyoto Animation who for all these years
were just training levelling ups and now
they have reached their absolute final
form of cute girl animation but if I
can't go with movies even though I can
never get into little witch academia
even I have to admit how breathtaking
some of the cuts were if Magus Bryan was
able to give a magical atmosphere little
which was magic in motion now if only
there was something more I could
actually
slice-of-life feels like a bit of a
cluttered category as it looks like the
awards have combined slice-of-life in
romance so I'm just gonna split these up
myself slice-of-life was an easy
decision for me because aside from what
I'm sure is most people's pick being in
comedy girls last tour was a show about
cute girls doing cute things and I
actually liked it yes that's right cute
Maui girls have finally broken down gone
[ __ ] T Giga can I'm not sure
exactly why with the juxtaposition of
cute girls exploring a desolate bleak
post-apocalyptic world with such an
innocent charm sprinkled in with some
life philosophy created this atmosphere
that was the perfect balance of
light-hearted goodness and
thought-provoking moments romance on the
other hand had some very strong
contenders I loved em mo junkies take
out relationships form via online
interactions even if it did end up
becoming coincidences the anime and I
really really enjoyed the comedic look
at different couples incident so that
sitted suited but I could never
pronounce the [ __ ] name so much so
that if I can't put neo yo kyo this can
also be my pick for comedy but for
romance the show I want to talk about is
sukiyaki Rey
it's rare to be able to find a romance
series that feels so grounded it's a
series that explores teenage
relationships in a way you don't
normally see in anime for one the
characters in this anime don't
particularly feel like anime characters
in the typical sense
nothing is overdramatize nothing is
overplayed it just feels real if you're
looking for a show that portrays the
innocence of genuine teenage romance
this is your show but I thought I want
to say as it already cared too much
about every other category so let's just
get to the big boy award
this is it the big one and this was a
tough decision I mean on one hand I had
my shown in trash site loving just how
much Hiroaki is bringing the genre back
Swiss roots or made in the best
completely blown me away or rocky goes
beautifully crafted series help I only
talked about the phenomenal CG in land
of lustrous but it was just a great show
all around and god I'm pretty sure I'm
the only one who had as much fun with
re-creators as I did despite everything
but there can only be one winner
which is why my pick for anime of the
year 2017 goes to you never seeing it so
defy for being the best anime I played
oh yeah it's made in abyss made in abyss
was my favorite anime this year voting
is now open for the awards at the anime
Awards calm for some of the categories
so you can go there to vote or check out
the nominees I trust you all to make the
right decision and not to be swayed by
my opinions at all but aside from that
thank you very much to Robert Hahn Bork
kay must live basil Patrick Madsen Jared
cattell Vincent Mooney Lau Ken and
everyone else on patreon for helping to
support me for this month and making
this video possible I'm really hoping I
could say goodbye to 2017 anime now and
start completely fresh
so until then quick outro today I've
been gig art and I will see you all next
time
[Music]